[inaudible] joining me today is an actor,
a standup comic,
the host of American Ninja Warrior,
and a guy whose birthday today,
Matt Iseman. Happy Birthday. Well,
thank you so much. I'm, I'm a little under
the weather. I'm a little hoarse here,
but this is a great birthday gift.
I always say one of the great choices
since I moved out to La was always want to
make sure I,
I perform,
I do something on my birthday because
that's what I love doing. So this is it.
This is my gift to myself.
How old are you? I'm,
I'm 40 48 40 48 which sounds so
old and yet I don't does that?
I don't know that it's
42 48 no longer now.
48 sounds old because I still in my
head see myself in my twenties yeah,
and it's hard. It's really
hard to shift that, that, that,
that thought process because I'm still
still, I'm dating a girl, but no kids,
so no commitment, none of those
responsibilities. I know you're married.
I think those are the kinds of
things that make you those little,
the markers in life that
might make you feel, okay,
I've matured but I've regressed
in everything I've done.
I talked about Ninjas for living.
I do stand up comedy,
so there's nothing that would make me
feel like an adult other than seeing that
48 next to my name and somehow
through it all at 48 years.
And maybe it's that you don't
have kids big smile on your face,
so you're doing something,
you know, I think, um,
I was a naturally enthusiastic kid. My
mom, you know, they, they called me,
they might the sunshine boy and
uh, I, I think, you know, the,
the word I always used,
if there was one adjective I would say
to describe myself who was enthusiastic,
I get excited about things.
And that's one of the,
one of the things I think that was
what it was a gift for me and, and to,
to have found a career where
you get rewarded for that.
And especially your shield
like Ninja Warrior, which
deals in hype and hyperbole,
where the more enthusiastic I am,
the better it is.
And that's become a thing onto itself.
We'll talk. It really is and it's, it's,
it's been, uh, it's,
I think also having switched careers,
uh,
midstream in life gave me
such an appreciation for
being able to do something
that I love because you look at so many
people and I always think of the song
working for the week,
everybody's working for the weekend.
That idea of a job is supposed to be toil.
It's supposed to be arguous.
It's supposed to be something you do to
provide for your family and then allow
you to have that free time.
We've found a way to disrupt the system
and do something we love. It's bizarre,
right? It's the best. And
it's one of those things of
if you can do it, and, and,
and I, I credit this to my dad deserves
the credit. Cause I, you know, I was a,
I was a doctor.
My Dad's a doctor and he was a professor
of medicine at the University of
Colorado where I was doing residency and
my dad is a world renowned physician.
He's the man I respect more than any
other person on this planet. He is,
he is the smartest, the best, the kindest,
the wisest man I've ever known or
you type the wrong ice minutes. Dude.
You totally do. My Dad is, my dad is,
he's a legend. I Yo, he's iron Mike.
He is just,
and,
and so to be [inaudible] following
in his footsteps and to know,
to feel like a, obviously I think
he was, he was very proud of it.
So when I sensed that medicine wasn't
my passion and that I needed to take a
step back and reevaluate because I
couldn't in good conscience be a doctor,
knowing my heart wasn't 100% in it,
I felt like I was a fraud.
I felt like I was not doing a service to
my patients and certainly not to myself
that the scariest moment
was telling my dad.
And I remember when I told him the first
words, he said, we're life is short.
Do what makes you happy.
So I've got that very quote from your
dad right here because it's the first
thing that you say on your about page,
on your site all the time.
Because in a certain way it sort of
sounds cliche. Do what makes you happy.
It is cliche.
It's almost the best advice or only
advice that you could get to that one.
I don't at a certain
level. Yeah. You know,
certainly it's not a Shakespearian line,
but I thought it was just, you know,
particularly for him to say it
at a moment when very easily,
probably most parents would
be, you're crazy. There's,
there's a lot of money invested in
this education. This is a stable job.
You don't walk away from
it for him to instead say,
all we care about is you being happy.
And you know,
I've talked to them so many times about
it and marveled at that he could have
mustered those words. Cause, uh, my
dad's an amazing man and he's also,
he worked hard for
everything he had. And, uh,
I was very fortunate to have
more opportunities because
of his hard work and the
work of my mom. And,
and, uh, I, I think too,
you know, when, when he says, I'm like,
how can I ever repay that? He say,
just if you ever have kids
someday do the same for them.
It's that pay it forward
mentality. And it's that thing
of, I don't know, it's, uh,
it makes me appreciate though
the opportunity that I have.
I know how lucky I am to be out here
getting to do this and how lucky I am to
have tried medicine and learn so much
from it and learned so much and be given
so much perspective about what truly
is life or death and to be out here in
entertainment where we feel like
everything is life or death,
but it's just silliness. It's silliness.
And it's so much fun what we get to do.
Yet we still do have a chance
to make a difference. Yeah.
Well you can do something real. It's
still enjoyable. Yeah. But wait, so,
so let's back up a bit. So
your dad's a doctor. Yeah.
Was it just sort of a foregone conclusion
that you were going to? No, no,
he wasn't even, he never pressured
me into it. It was more I think,
lead by example.
It was either,
the funny thing was I think at eight
I kind of had a crisis during college
because I worked,
there was just in growing up,
it was you work hard, you play sports,
you go to school, you excel, you achieve,
and that's the path you're on.
But I never kind of stopped to say stuff
right there, work hard and succeed.
Right? But I never stopped to
think what's, what's the end?
Where am I headed? And so then, you know,
when I kind of poked my head up
midway through college, you go,
w where am I headed? And I looked
around and I thought, you know,
that's when I thought, okay,
I like science. I like people.
And I looked at my dad as someone who
I respected tremendously and saw the
satisfaction he got from
medicine. Now, I think he,
he was a little impression in seeing that
medicine was changing and doctors were
losing autonomy and that,
you know,
medicine today is radically
different than it was 30 years ago.
So I think he saw that there was probably
going to be some disruptions in the
field of medicine, but um, it
seemed on paper the perfect job.
But it's so interesting, you know,
that's what you realize is, you know,
it's like when you watch
sports or something, you know,
you don't play a game on paper.
You don't live your life on paper.
What looks like it might be perfect that
sometimes it's just that divine spark
is missing that, that whatever
it is, that intangible thing.
And I'm so lucky to have somehow stumbled
into performing and finding that I
love an audience.
I love being in front of the camera.
I love doing standup comedy.
I love being on Ninja Warrior.
I mean these are the things
where no matter how sick I am,
no matter how tired I am,
if it's like when you get
onstage and you have an audience,
I just feel like I feel present.
I feel alive. It's such a rush.
Did you have a moment when you realized
it was wrong for you? Sort of slow thing.
There was a loud moment. It was in
January of 1999 I was in the ICU.
It was probably three in the morning.
You know, I'd, I'd been up for 18 hours.
We were getting slammed.
I think we had seven admin.
So this super sick people
are rolling in and I'm a uh,
resident. I man, I'm an intern first,
first year out of med school and I
had a second year with me and there's,
there's also an attending when
he wasn't in the hospital.
So at this point the guy was like
the person who was overseeing me,
it was just like,
just you got to the rights of mortars,
you got to make some choices,
make some decisions for these people.
And I'm all of a sudden realizing these
people's lives now are in my hands.
And I just thought,
I'm sitting there going,
I want to be skiing or playing Nintendo
or, or I don't want to be here.
I didn't feel like this is the
moment I've trained for it.
It wasn't like er I jumped on top
of a Gurney and started doing CPR.
It was just this moment
of I felt like a fraud.
I felt like my heart,
you know it all this training,
all this and I loved medical school.
I loved the problem solving elements of
it but I realized, I think there was,
there's just something, I think there
are jobs and there are callings.
Medicine is a calling. It is not
something that you just do nine to five.
It is something that consumes you
that you are obsessed with your,
your patients are obsessed with being
up to date on the information and giving
them the best care possible. And if
you're, if you don't hear that calling,
if it's just a job for you,
that's awful because it is,
it is such a consuming
profession and you know,
and when you look at the opportunity cost
of somebody who goes to medical school
and is going six figures into that versus
my friends who went into finance and
or making six figures and then during
residency you're making subsistence level
wages.
As your debt continues to grow,
some of these people will
never get out from under that,
that debt and and you end up working
this career and making choices that you
might not want to or practicing the way
you would want to or given the level of
care that you would want to.
When you think I,
I do believe that health care in America
is going to see a radical shift in the
next few decades because people aren't
going to be able to afford to go into
medicine anymore or want to.
It's such a fascinating
thing because it's like, wow,
you train your whole life or something.
Okay, now you make, you have this moment,
right? You have to wake up moment. What
happens in the next day? So you know,
my mom,
my mom said something like there's no
wasted education and she's so right.
Like so when I came out to
la, I literally, I packed
up, I packed up a u haul,
I moved out to La September one
99 and I got the a la weekly,
I got the back pain.
This is like bad movie version of this is,
this is John's playing Mecasa and,
and so I just started finding open mikes
and I just started going to open mikes
and I'm just, honestly,
when I came out here,
it wasn't as though I said I'm
going to be a standup comedian.
Part of me thought I'm going to take
a year and I'm going to grow up.
I'm going to get this out of my system
and realize I'm fortunate to be a doctor
and I'll go back and adult. That's
kind of what I thought 20 years ago.
So you're late,
late twenties,
late twenties and I can't really
understand the open mic situation.
It's the God awful. I remember
when I was doing it. And it's like,
it's like a terrible, you know, couple
of years that you have to do as a comic,
as you're figuring out your shit.
But I remember there would be doctors,
they're lawyers, they're, there
would be professionals and I,
every time I saw one of them, I'd be
like, what in the world is wrong with you?
Why are you here? You're a real
person. You're a functioning person.
And yet they were there because they
had something in them that there's
something, there's
something, you know, I think,
I think everybody has that
we all search for purpose.
We all search for something that,
that, that ignites a fire in this.
And rare is the person that finds,
I think, the job that does that.
And I think we're so lucky to have found
something. And again, it even gets luck.
Um,
well you're okay.
We took the chance and
we certainly went out. I,
I still think there is a certain
amount of, of fortune or,
or circumstance or something, you know, I,
I'm not gonna say I'm Christopher
Columbus who boldly decided to explore the
frontiers of the job world
and walked away from medicine.
I was lucky in that my family supported
me. I was lucky in that when I came out,
you know, you meet the right people. Look,
luck is what prep preparation besides
whatever cliches we want to spout out.
Yeah. I just thought you'd have a good
one there that I, I don't, I don't know.
I mean, I'd never been called on that day.
You're very good. I, I'm not saying it.
Is it luck?
I do think it's partly luck her kids
made or magic of just putting the work in
all those things. Having said
that, you're right. I think, um,
that once I realized it was this,
that's where the medicine came in so
handy in that medicine taught me such a
discipline and, and such, uh,
an ability to work hard and
process information and to
just withstand a river of
shit being dumped on you
where you're like, this is,
this is easy, right? I'm not,
I'm not on third call for 36 hours.
You're asking me to sit here with craft
services and have someone do make up and
be pampered that fine. Yeah, fine. Great.
I love this can be a lot of waiting
around, which is quite cool. It is.
And you know, the, the, it's
a business. Well here's,
here's where it really helped is
Hollywood is a business of no, you,
you go out for a hundred things
and 99 times you're told no,
and often you're told nothing.
You're not given a reason why you might've
been amazing. You're never told why.
And if you don't have something that
provides you with that sense of self,
that sense of it's okay, I know I am
talented. If you don't have that belief,
then I think people really crumble.
And the people who succeed aren't
necessarily the most talented.
They're the ones who persist.
They're the ones who can slog it out.
And you know this, we, we,
we've seen it the 1520 year overnight
success where somebody pops and like,
oh my God, this guy came out of
nowhere. And you're like, no,
I've been doing it for 20 years.
And they finally,
they got recognized and that's why they're
so good is because they've been doing
it for 20 years. I heard Susie
Essman, you know the comedians. Yeah.
Curb your enthusiasm.
I heard her say that.
Everyone says she's an overnight success
and she always goes, you know what?
She's got a great piety match.
She's always like, well,
where the fuck were you for
20 years? Yeah. It's like,
yeah, there's a lot of work,
you know. And honestly
though it, it's a, it,
it does two things. A, it
makes you appreciate it, but B,
it also makes you ready for it because
if I come out here and gotten a show one
weekend, you, you wouldn't
have had the chops.
You wouldn't have known how to do it.
You wouldn't have had the ability
to know right from wrong or,
or to make the right decisions.
And I think that's what you learn over
those 20 years of hard knocks. You know,
you, you start to see, um,
you get these opportunities
performing in front of four people.
So when you go out there and you're like,
there is nothing,
I hosted a live show on
the history channel, um,
with Travis Pastrana ray recreated
evil Knievel stunts for three hours.
Half the time people are just like,
just talk. And you're like, okay,
I can do that. I've done that. That,
that's what I've been trained for.
And so it was so great to feel like
you, you, you're ready for things.
I did. I was just talking
about celebrity apprentice.
So I was with Arnold
Schwarzenegger this weekend and um,
the show got politicized.
Nobody watched it.
But what was great about it was it was
so much fun for me because it called on.
I felt everything I had done
in my life to that point,
whether it'd been playing sports or being
a doctor or going to school or a stand
up or hosting our w anything you,
you called on all these different seals
and it's so much fun when you feel ready,
when an opportunity comes and you're like,
I am ready for this opportunity.
There's nothing you could throw
at me that I can't handle. And,
and I would much rather have someone go,
where have you been?
Then see you too early and go, miles.
All right, but next. All right,
so we've got the beginnings of
a Nice Hollywood story here,
but for a content, it took
a turn for the worse. Right?
Then you moved to La crumbles.
No, but, but, you know,
they say the comedy comes from pain. Um,
uh, I'm not seeing like, well, you know,
I think I always say people
go into a, they, those people,
I think, I think there's,
um, I think people go into
comedy for one of two reasons.
They weren't hugged enough as a child
pain or they were hugged too much.
I was definitely the latter where I
had a mother who just showered me with
attention and affection and praise
and she was always Matt. Oh,
that's so funny.
Whatever I did was amazing and she
made me believe have this ridiculous
confidence this. And she was
always there. She was always there.
I had this unbelievable sense
of a safety net from my mom and,
and my dad.
And I think that that's what gave me
the confidence to think I could come out
here and take a swing and be okay and
know that I could fall flat on my face and
either go back to Madison and my parents
wouldn't disown me and, and, but,
but ultimately I believed, yeah, I,
what I've realized in life is nothing
is certain. And, and I look at,
I have a ton of friends
who are in finance.
I had a friend who was at bear
Stearns when it imploded and you know,
saw people lose $60 million overnight and
these guys who thought they were going
to be able to retire all of a sudden
an hour out of a job and broke.
And you know, you go into, you choose
some of these careers thinking, all right,
I'm going to work my ass off,
but it'll pay off in the end.
And you realize there nothing's
guaranteed. And so I think too,
what I realized is the best bet in
life you can make is to bet on yourself
because that's where you have the most
control. And so while these career I'm at,
we're in well is so fickle and so on
the surface fickle where, you know,
my show, they live week to week
with ratings. Oh my God, it's,
it's up a pointer. It's down a point.
And you think it could end at any moment.
And, and we, and we make
our peace with that.
But ultimately what I've realized
is having been out here 19 years,
I've worked and I,
I just have to have this confidence.
The only way I can sleep at
night as to say if it goes away,
something else will come,
I'll bet on myself.
And I think that's one of those
things in life that, um, is,
is hard to get to. But if you can, is a
great position to be in is when you say,
I'd rather bet on myself
than someone else,
than relying on someone else
to provide me as you have,
you've gone out on your own. Yeah. I mean,
I feel that very intimately because even
just in the last couple of months with
this patriotic thing,
the rubber met the road and I was like,
can I make a move here?
That's a huge risk and not,
and I did make the move and it, and it's
worked. And I've found that if you're,
if you're just present enough and aware
enough of what really is going on and
you put in the work that you
generally make the right moves,
you're going to do some missteps
along the way. Yeah. But,
but that generally speaking,
the right path, we'll kind of,
you've got to shoot though.
You've got to take that shot.
I've got to think it's a,
you know, with Ninja Warrior,
one of the things we see is
everybody falls, everybody's
going to have a misstep.
Everyone's gonna have a show,
get canceled or something and you just
get back up and you learn from it and you
keep going. Some people are devastated
by that. Some people can't handle that,
that failure. And you just have to
realize that it's not a failure. It's,
it's just this was one
thing that didn't work,
but hopefully it'll lead you
to the next thing that does.
Are you shocked at the amount of people
that are just afraid to do something
special now? They're like, I get it. I
mean, again, you know, I, I think I was,
I was very lucky to have parents
who were incredibly supportive.
So,
and I was also like,
I think to have been exposed to
enough. So even though I, you know,
my life had always been very much
set towards, you know, sports,
school achievement, it
was set towards, you know,
lawyer finance doctor is something that,
there was enough exposure to think
that it was possible to have it.
Outside of that.
So for a random person who's growing up
without parents who are encouraging them,
I think it's hard.
I know how lucky I was to have parents
who gave me that sense of confidence and
that sense of anything is possible.
So for the average person, I, the
people who amaze me are the people I,
you know, I want that movie.
I Tonya about Tonya Harding.
One of the things that struck me,
there were two things that struck me.
One was how remarkable it was that this
girl from the trailer parks went into
this sport and through sheer
will and athleticism, um,
made it to the top.
But the thing I didn't like about the
movie was that while it purported to tell
her story,
I felt there was a little winking and
judgmental of she still white trash
trailer park.
And when you told,
when you really saw the story of how her
mom would hire people to yell at her,
I don't know that, you know, you
want it to be a sympathetic figure,
but at least you understood what
this woman overcome and the,
for the tenacious,
the ferocious to tenacity,
she had to persevere in, in this
world where she was such an outsider.
Those are the people who
amaze me. Yeah, I mean, I,
I know I was very fortunate to,
to have a lot of opportunities that
gave me the confidence to take my shot.
So look, any other thing was like when I
moved out here, I didn't have a family.
I didn't have kids,
I didn't have responsibilities.
So for that person who's sitting
there, those are the people, you know,
if you have a wife and
kids and you can say,
I'm going to risk our future
to take the shot, that's,
those are the people I think
I really salute. Right?
It's a little harder to the doctor or
the lawyer or the finance guy or the
janitor who is like,
I got some kids and now I'm quitting
and I'm going to do stand up comedy.
We've got a different situation. Yeah. And
it's, it's, it is hard and it's, it's, uh,
you know, one of the things I love
with American Ninja Warrior, uh,
to shamelessly promote,
but,
but it's to see these people who have
families who have jobs and still find time
to train for this ridiculous
thing because it's their passion.
And when you see that it's, that's what
I love about it is because I think it's,
it's kind of, it's sums up the
American dream of it's just bootstraps.
It's that there's no, there is
no secret formula. I'd work hard.
Have you seen people that have been to
absolutely wrapped up in that thing,
whatever that thing may be, be it, be
it comedy, be it, you know? Sure, sure.
Of course. Of course. You know, I think, I
think there's a, you know, there, there's,
there's obsession and, and a healthy
obsession. Then there's a, you know,
a consuming obsession. I think with
American Ninja Warrior for the most part,
um, there's, uh, there's the
community is, there's such a,
a positive supportive community that
we haven't seen people, you know,
go off the rails. And
the good news is, look,
I don't think any of them are know
using pds. They're too expensive.
These guys are making a lot of money.
I think they really are leading a
healthy lifestyle, but more importantly,
it's a supportive lifestyle. But
certainly with comedy you've seen lots of,
you know,
lots of friends who've in comedy is a
very lonely existence when you're on the
road.
Now I'm lucky that with TV I get to do
comedy selectively and not have to be out
there 40 50 weeks a year in strange cities
where you're working two hours a day
and 22 hours,
you're in a strange city with nothing to
do and no one around. And that is, uh,
that is a existence that's
kind of fun when you're 20.
But when you get into your forties
is incredibly lonely in your fifties.
It's very hard.
Yeah.
I remember when I was maybe six
or seven years into stand up,
I was doing some of my first road gigs.
I was opening at bananas in Poughkeepsie,
New York for bobcat. Stop bragging.
Oh, bottom bobcat's great.
He was really great actually,
and the shows were sold out to the
and to move us out of the club.
He was in a best western, best
western in Poughkeepsie. Wow.
Move us out of the comedy club into a ball
room, so it's, you know, I don't know,
five,
600 people.
I think we did six shows over three
nights or something like that,
but I remember on the last night
that the show ends and I'm alone in
Poughkeepsie and it's freezing out
and I'm starving and the is closed and
there's nothing else.
I leave there and I remember I walk up
to the vending machine at the end of the
hallway and I got a skittles and
I laid in bed eating skittles,
you know, best what's going to be
kipsy after one of your best shows,
the best shows of my life. And I was
like, I'm actually depressed. Yeah.
That's how warp this thing,
if you have some of those moments,
I remember that I was sitting there
and yeah, same thing like in Ohio,
walking around going, what
am I, what am I doing?
Walking to Mcdonald's at two in the
morning. But, but it's, I don't know,
I thought if you did you see the
documentary comedian with Jerry Seinfeld,
but you know the story of the band is
like walking through the snow and they see
these families celebrating Christmas.
What do it live like that
and I think there is, there
is just a certain, you know,
you have a certain mindset
of I have to be on stage,
but it does get hard and it does get
lonely and so it's nice to find something
that allows you a little more
stable lifestyle. And with,
with Ninja warrior, we're really
only shooting about 23 days a year.
And so the majority of the
time I can be around La, me,
around my girlfriend and we can lead
largely a normal existence and pick and
choose when I go out and for stand up.
And so I right now I'm in in in a very
fortunate situation but it could change
at any moment so I'm also at the same
time there's always a fire under my ass.
That thing of you always
have to be hustling to make
sure to find the next thing
because as we've seen, things can
get taken away from you very quickly.
You could say something at any
moment that could end your,
so this is one of this.
This sounds really why one of the things
that's most fascinating to me when you
make a living with words right now,
one of the things that amazes me is that
the artistic community and comedians in
particular haven't been more vocal
in supporting people because again,
while I am a clean comic and the shows
I do are completely family friendly and
and I try to be in the middle of the road,
I also know that those people who are
out there on the edges, guys like Doug,
Stan hope or Jim Norton,
those who are pushing those envelopes,
they're keeping that area
of speech protected because
once you've seen an area,
once it's taken away. Once we say, okay,
you don't, we can't joke about that.
You never get that back.
And to me, it's not that I,
where I feel the power of comedy is,
is the power to talk about very difficult,
very touchy subjects in a way,
in a disarming way through humor.
Now I've had rheumatoid
arthritis and I've had cancer,
and when I tell those stories,
I tell them as funny as possible.
Those are stories that you know aren't
necessarily the best stories to tell,
but it's amazing what you can
talk about when you use humor.
And when we take some of those
topics off the table for comedy,
I think we really lose an important
tool for us to communicate and for us to
find common ground.
And that's why it's so amazing to
me as we see this now where there's,
there's this almost this agreement of,
yeah,
we're agreeing certain topics now are
no longer, you can't joke about it,
or am I am, we're going to go back
and apply it. Retroactive. Yeah.
Well did you see just in the last
couple of weeks that the producers,
a family guy said that they're
not going to do gay jokes anymore.
It's like you guys have done gay.
Everyone has, I mean they're,
they're one of their iconic bits.
Was that musical musical.
Cotillion musicals, but which one was
it? Everyone has aids. Oh, ever. Yeah.
David's aids. You know where
they, they just kept repeating it.
Seth Macfarlane and again,
it's like,
or every character is a ridiculous
stereotype, right? It's like which groups?
How do we decide which groups we are not
going to make jokes about these really
actually equality is that you,
everyone will make fun of everyone.
That's what real equality. I think
South Park does that better than anyone.
Whether everything is fair game or
nothing is very, now having said that,
if you want to evolve, if
you say, you know what,
I no longer want to tell those jokes,
that's fine.
More power to you make the
choice of your own volition.
Whatever you find funny is great.
Maybe you've had some personal awakened
whatever it is. But I just think,
again, what I don't like is the idea of
people saying you can't joke about it.
Like if you choose not to, great. Again,
I choose not to joke about
a lot of things. I've just
not comfortable. You know,
I always picture my grandma
in the crowd or my mom.
I want people to be entertained. I don't
want to alienate people. That's me.
But I love listening to some of the
filthiest comics talk about things and,
or joke about cancer or things
that have impacted me. And,
and I find it hilarious and I find
it Cathartic to laugh about it.
And I think because someone else doesn't,
you know,
may have had a bad experience with it,
doesn't mean that someone shouldn't
be able to joke about it. Um, I,
I just think that this is
a really interesting time
because social media gives
voice to people and we see where one
or two people protesting can change a
network.
And that's what's,
what's remarkable is that as we really
don't see these networks saying, you know,
99% of people may not care.
They came to this smaller percentage.
And again, often it'd be nice
for them to say, okay boycott,
we stand behind our performers. We
stand behind this content. Yeah.
So it's a weird time to
be a comic. I mean, so I,
I did stand up for 12 years in New York,
then I came here, I started doing this,
I was doing something else that I liked.
I stopped doing it.
This can be even more
dangerous though day.
So now I started again in June and
now I'm selling out clubs all over the
country and I don't care that much.
So I'm having the most fun
I've ever had on stage.
I do an hour and I'm messing
around with the crowd.
And how did you have people coming out
to see you? [inaudible] is the best.
So that way, that's a game changer
because when people come out and they,
you know, they're there for you,
they know something about you,
you can do insight or stuff as opposed
to just being the eighth white guy at a
12th comics and they're like, who
the hell? That guy was hilarious.
What was the name of, you know, and
then, and then that's it. But, um,
but it's an odd time to be doing stand
up knowing that people could be in the
crowd recording you waiting to take
you down. And they are, and you know,
and that's the workshop that that's,
you know, that's not where you're,
that's what you're learning the medicine
where you're performing the surgery.
It is. And, and, and no
other, you know, Jim Norton,
I give so much credit for,
for talking about, um,
how comics are held to a different
standard than any other artists.
So say you're an actor and you go on
Svu and you play the most reprehensible
character. Nobody believes that
you are that person. Right?
But as a comedian,
what they don't understand is sometimes
you will say something hyperbolic.
You will say something
ironically to make a point.
It's not what you actually believe,
but because it's Dave Ruben saying it,
they take you literally going, wait,
you missed the entire of the joke.
You missed the Joe Guy.
My point was the exact opposite.
But nobody will give you
the credit for the context.
And people often just see the written
words and it's, it's really unfortunate.
And, and, and again, what
people don't understand, and,
and Jim was just talking about this with
Judd Apatow in the case of Louis C K is
jokes don't spring fully formed.
Jokes can take weeks, months,
years to be honed.
It's so hard,
especially if it's a topic that is
delicate to find the phrasing and to say,
I'm going to tackle a subject that nobody
thinks I can make funny and I'm going
to find a way to make it funny.
It's going to take me awhile and I'm
going to stumble through and I'm going to
get some groans and I can get
some people alienated. Not me.
I talk about various, you know,
ridiculous things. But yeah,
I appreciate those comments.
Who can go there and say,
take a subject that I would say,
I will never laugh at this.
You made me laugh at this.
Despite that,
then I think Doug Stanhope is one of the
best examples of someone who will take
the most taboo subjects and make you
laugh despite you might be vehemently
opposed to the way he thinks,
but he's funny. Yeah. And
when you do that, there's,
it's such a way of opening up your
mind to saying, okay, let me, let me,
let me rethink these things.
Or maybe it doesn't, but it,
but it just proves that I think anything
can be funny. Anything can be fair game.
And I think it's important that we allow
comedians to have this full range of
words and emotions to use because that's,
we're talking about the human condition.
And I think comedians really do have a
great job in that we can bring up some of
these topics in a way that, you know,
when you see it happen on Tucker Carlson,
people might go to fisticuffs,
but in the comedy club you'll laugh
about it and go, you know what? Maybe,
maybe my crazy uncles, not so
crazy. Maybe we can talk. Yeah,
well that's why it's so strange that
I'm doing this because I feel like they
dragged me into it because
I've seen a lot of comics who,
I love that if become the word police,
they've become the hysterical. Right?
Who on Twitter who are calling for books
not to be printed and all of this stuff.
[inaudible] I always think it's
like, man, if Karlyn was alive,
what would he be doing? Right, right.
He'd be making funny shit. Patrice O'neil,
same guy or, or, or would he be
demanding that people be booted off?
Platforms are silenced or otherwise and
it's like what a strange place for an
artist.
And you see eventually it consumes them.
Eventually it comes back to bite
them because nobody is perfect.
Nobody, nobody is without a
flaw. Nobody's without, you know,
having nobody has led their
lives. Like, Jesus, we,
we've all done something or said something
or tried to make a joke that at some
point if you went back people would say
that's wrong and you'd be like, okay,
but that was 10 years ago or any,
it is an odd time.
I think that that people
aren't particularly,
comedians aren't more supportive instead
are really leading this book burning
charge. Well that's why this,
this uh, family guy thing
irked me so much. It's like,
you guys did this for 20 years.
I'm not even mad.
I don't know if sets even
that in front of the,
I don't even know if he's that
much involved in the show anymore,
but like it's like you did this for 20
years and now it's like you're on the
other side of success
kind of. So like, are you,
are we a more tolerant society because
we're not going to joke about certain
people now. Does that make us
more tolerant? I like that.
It's interesting is odd to me.
You know, it's really, it's a,
it's a funny thing where, and I'd love
to have him here and that's not even a,
it's really about a judgment on him. I
just want to deal with this shit. Right?
Why this and then what about what other
topics? Right? So it's like, okay,
so you can't make fun of gays. Like
should we get the, where's the list?
Where's the list loans? That
list, who owns who judges it,
who's, you know, and, and,
and, and that list is shifting. And what's
crazy is, you see, it's not the joke,
it's who says it. Yeah. Because
you know the same person,
two people can say the same joke.
One person gets celebrated,
one person gets vilified. So it's not
the words, it's who's saying that?
And that's wrong. Like it should
be. Absolutely. It should be.
Either this is a fair game or not.
It shouldn't be based on what we're
getting to is, you know, papers please,
you have to have the papers to
prove that you are of this group.
So you can talk about this topic.
And it's like either the topic is fair
game where it's not either everyone can
talk about it. Uh, that's what
I believe. But again, you know,
I realize I'm, I'm, I'm the
white male, so I, I, you know,
I also am, oh wait, listen,
I don't know. Oh No,
wait, what? I've been with you this whole
time. Why should you shut up and listen,
I always,
you're doing that with a little tongue
in cheek is I always feel the need.
This is one of the what I hate
that. Oh, now you're doing it.
You're going to fill in the details,
your coffee,
you feel they need tissue caveats where
you feel the need to say I, you know,
I, I don't like, uh, homophobia,
but I think family guy can make
jokes who unit where it's like,
of course now you know,
where you normally would assume
that's the concession you're making.
Just cause you're a good person.
I think I used to do a lot of that too.
And now I'm just sort of
over. It's like, well,
it's because you own your platform and
I see might be watching this. So, right.
But nothing,
you've said he's homophobic.
Obviously we're talking
about the nature jokes or,
or that they don't want to Apu
and the Simpsons anymore. Well,
you see it's craziness.
What I don't like also was the guilt
by association where, you know,
I thought Mike Rowe said that someone
was criticizing micro for going on,
I don't know, rush Limbaugh and
then Rachel Maddow, you know,
and people were complaining on both sides.
He's like,
going on a show doesn't mean I implicitly
endorse every single stance that
person has.
It means I'm talking to somebody,
I'm expressing my opinions.
They may have different opinions.
It's a discussion and I just wish we
would allow more of that because otherwise
all you're saying is people I approve
of talking to people I approve of.
So all you're hearing is
what you want to hear. Yeah.
I think that's what we miss is reasoned
people having reason discussions.
Unfortunately, when you turn
on the TV, we know hyperbole,
hyperbole moves the needle. I, you
know, yeah, it's an amazing run,
but at least it's not, you know,
politically and, and you see that light.
I think that's, it's a,
you know, I, I, and I,
I told you before I give you
full credit what I love is,
and Joe Rogan does the same thing.
I think you guys are willing to have
people on you might disagree with and
you're not looking for a gotcha moment.
You're not looking for confrontation.
You're looking for understanding,
like, help me understand your position.
Let me help you understand my position.
Maybe there's agreement,
maybe there isn't. But for the listeners,
at least they're being informed. There's,
they're hearing different points of view.
Does it strike you as odd that
that seems so unique these days?
Like I've had people in here, I think
people don't seek it out. Yeah. I think,
you know, and I think, um, I, I, you
know, we look at the universities,
we look at places where I think
people are taught, you know,
diversity of thought or a
different thought that there,
that there is one right daughter that
you shouldn't have these discussions.
And I think that's, you know,
we've always, I mean I look at,
I look at medicine and, and it's, it's
so amazing how medicine, you know,
you think you deal in absolutes,
you think you deal in complete science,
black and white, but we see a
new study talked about sunscreen,
how actually sunscreen may
not be healthy because we,
the rally is melanoma,
which is completely devil,
only about 1% of skin
cancers and it is awful,
but people are putting
so much sunscreen on,
they're not getting any of
the beneficial vitamin D.
We're seeing an increase
in cardiac disease.
Cardiac disease is killing so
many more people than melanoma.
So now dermatologists are thinking
maybe we shouldn't be wearing as much
sunscreen.
So you see these truths that we thought
were absolute being challenged because
people look at the data,
they look at empirical things
when it comes to life and death.
We're able to do that when
it comes to political topics,
which are just as important.
I think it's much harder to do it because
they're so politically charged that
people don't want to look at the data.
They want to look at how they feel about
them or are these emotions are what it
stirs up.
And if someone presents a counterargument
you're dismissed or debunked or d
platform. Yeah. What do you consider
yourself politically? I think I'm,
I'm a little more, you know,
I, I am Vietnam free speech.
I am vehemently, people should live their
lives the way they want to live them.
Um, I think I'm moderate
to right. Would, would,
would probably be it.
I don't like the government taxing us to,
and I don't think the government is great
at a lot of things like health care.
Um, but at the same time, you know,
really audio function in
Hollywood with the set of ideas.
And here's the other thing is I tend
not to talk politics because it isn't my
purview. Might like I'm an entertainer
and I'm the last person. They,
people are getting their political
opinions from the host of American Ninja
Warrior. I think, again, I
think for me, I what I like is,
you know, for me, I never
talked politics on stage.
I never, you know, I would
rather bring people together.
I'm not looking to alienate people
or, or try to be clever. It's,
I think that's, I leave to Lewis Black or
guys who are very good at that. That's,
that's her area to tackle the political
humor. That's just not my thing. Um,
I, I think I, again, I
just think in Hollywood,
the one thing I think
that is so important is,
is the exchange of ideas.
And that's what I think is
being compromised right now.
And that's the thing that I try to,
um,
the year that I really want people
to, to fight for. Because again,
once we see that ground, we're
not getting it back. All right,
so let's shift to this binge.
You're warring warrior warrior for
something they love. When you say that it,
so it started out as a joke. It
actually, and you can hear I'm hoarse. I,
I am a very loud adds a little
something. Well, so this, this was,
I was in hosting the Arlo pro strongman
world series and Santa Monica,
so it was five hours nonstop of,
Oh look at him lifting this weight.
And when I went into the show,
uh, so for those who don't know,
American American Ninja Warrior
started out, it's a, it's a,
it was a Japanese show, Saas Gay. It
was poured into America and dubbed.
It started doing so well on g four.
They made an American
version in the second season.
They realized they had something
and they're like, okay,
we're going to put some money into this
and we're bringing in the new host.
And they found me and I think
they were looking for a Joe Rogan.
There's some bigger guys,
but I don't care. You know,
it's like the lights come up at 2:00 AM
in the morning and then like the pretty
girl goes, all right, I'll go home with
you. I might've been your last choice.
I'm just happy to be here.
Rogan's got enough stuff.
So I started doing this show and um,
you know,
we would be going for eight or nine hours
a day calling me runs and it's all 10
out of 10 because it was based
on the Japanese show. And so my,
my sports calling technique comes
just from years of watching sports,
watching the Japanese show and being
an enthusiastic, I am always yeah,
hyperbolic.
But it was really straining on the voice
since we were shooting these ins and
outs where it's coming up next on
American Ninja Warrior and I was a little
gravelly in the, and so I was kind
of making a point like, hey my,
my voice is kind of shot.
So I was like American Ninja Warrior and
the petitioner was like, Oh, do that,
do more of that.
So this is like in the fourth year,
if you watch the earlier seasons
I'm like, uh, next on American name.
I can't even do it cause I'm rally.
There was, it was none of that.
So it was just kind of born out of blowing
out my voice and now it's become like
the signature thing that I love
to do anything for your voice. I,
a lot of my friends who are still had
gone to a lot of voice coaches and tried
to, obviously they really
were so effective. It's um,
but I mean even on the
medical side of things,
just to make sure you're not
blowing out your book, you know,
I see an ENT on a regular basis.
I'll do,
so we'll go to Vegas and we'll do six
out of seven days where we're shooting at
night, but it's still a hundred
degrees in dust for, you know,
eight hours in a row, 10
out of 10 energy. And those,
I'll do ivs and anti inflammatories and
steroids just to try to maintain the
vocal cords in vocal rest. Um,
but I, you know, you, you, I'm,
I'm going back trying to
learn better technique. It's,
it's almost like rock singers. I look
at Brian Johnson from ACDC who was like,
you know,
that guy was doing it at 70
the most vocally taxing way.
So that's one of the things is,
is trying to learn how to preserve
the voice to work for that long.
Speaking of rock stars,
I saw this morning that you tweeted
something about Steve Perry from journey.
Now I love journey, love, love, love you.
You're my favorite band in the world.
I love Steve Perry. I love the
fact that he's back now. Cause he,
cause he had had some voice stuff
actually. Speaking of guys. Yeah. He,
I mean he basically lost
his voice for a while.
I can't say this completely on camera.
Suffice to say he kind of lives near
here and I may remain and I know the
Mexican joint that he goes to. So, uh,
so today we're going
to pull people to this.
Not Iceland's birthday it Steve Perry's
birth. They say Terri's birthday.
So Steve Birthday and I'm not, I'm
not lying. So for my thready Edward,
they never met him. Yeah. For I,
I've been a journey fan
since I can remember. And,
and I,
for my 30th birthday at the Brown Derby,
the last night of the Brown Derby,
we closed it down.
I hired a journey cover band and I
had them play it and I still have this
fantasy that someday on my birthday I'm
going to be singing faithfully or don't
stop believing in.
All of a sudden another guy's gonna
walk out behind me and it's going to be
Steve Perry and we're going to do a
duet together and arm and arm to singing
like faithfully at the end.
Yeah. That's my family. Steve,
if you're watching how your, I hope he's
a huge fan of Ninja warrior cause he,
I just listened to that voice. Yeah. I
think he had one of the most unique, yeah.
And Arnelle Pinatas. Remarkable
story. It's an incredible story,
but you listen to Steve and you listen
to the passion and the range and just the
unique notes that guy would hit.
It was incredible. I, I'm just,
I love journey.
I loved their songs.
I love the eighties I love the unabashed
passion and, and, and, and glory.
There's no cynicism in it.
It just awesome. Every,
every time I do stand up now or when I
do like a public speaking thing and the,
but you know, right before you start,
they go, well, what's going on,
do you want to go up to,
and the only thing that always pops
into my mind is separate ways by journey
that, that beginning, oh my God,
that video when they're playing the
keyboard on the wall, so much power,
so much power close chains that
by, I mean it's just, you know,
yeah. You don't stop believing
or any way you wanted it.
And they have so many great
songs that when you just hear it,
they're just toe tappers. And
I mean, granted, you know,
if you grew up in the 80s it was
the soundtrack of our youth. So,
so much of it takes us back to
there. But um, Steve Perry is just a,
he's one of, he's been one of
the, one of the great artists,
I think what journey has done and,
and I would love,
I saw them up in San Francisco and
show Schoen was shutting him out.
And I thought, I wonder if Steve's
going to come out on stage for the,
for the long of they didn't have,
yeah,
well they just got inducted to the
rock and yeah, I, it's, you know,
a lot of bad blood to I think
get over, but, but yeah. Anyway,
that's a sidebar for a side.
Let's get back to that Ninja
thing. Um, so like what,
like what's some of some sort of insider
something that you can give us about
what these guys are like that, that are
doing this of, you know, it's, it's a,
what you see is what the,
the amazing thing is they
really are the people you see.
They are these people who are incredibly
hardworking and so generous and
supportive of one another. We had, um,
a woman Maggie Thorn and she was,
she was open about that.
She was going through a really tough
divorce and she has three little girls.
And uh, during that time she started
traveling around the country,
visiting her Ninja sisters
as she called them,
people like Barclays Docket and Jessie
Flexible breadcrumb Michelle warranty.
And she just talked about how had
she not had this community, she,
she wasn't sure what she
would've done to get through it.
And you see it's been unlike
any other sport. I mean a,
we've only had one winner,
intense seasons. Like what
other show? Like I talked about,
like at the end of America's got talent,
you know, they'd come out and go,
well it turns out America doesn't
have talent there. And yet, you know,
it's a show where every single person
who's competing on the show has fallen at
one point. So it's a show that would
seem to be filled with failure.
And yet when you watch it, you feel like
you're seeing more success than ever.
And I think we've,
we've stumbled into a formula where
you see it's these are really everyday.
They're truly everyday people. They're
us. They are people who have jobs,
have families who've dealt with substance
abuse or cancer or the loss of a loved
one, whatever it is, loss of a job
and yet are trying to work through it.
And you see the obstacle courses,
just a metaphor for the obstacles
they've overcome in life. And you know,
we tell the,
the thing we do,
I think better than most shows is in
90 seconds we give you a reason to care
about these people and then we show you,
we let you cheer for them and it's
the Olympic formula of, I don't give,
I don't care about curling,
but you told me this guy works at ups.
He's got a new baby on the way and
it's like a Bruce Springsteen song.
Then when he's up there breast
and I'm like, Ooh, go buddy.
You Go Flynn's Jurgen
from Norway where you,
you just find yourself cheering
for him and I think it's this,
it's this thing of one of the
things I love, I love doing the,
like the strong man competition or
Ninja or I work with Travis Pastrana,
this evil thing.
I love watching people push the envelope
or do things they didn't think they
could do. I love people seeing people
have their moment because they,
one of the things in life
that helps define you,
that helps give you the confidence
is to have a Superbowl moment,
to have to have a moment where you, you,
when you're victorious in something,
whether it's you get a job or you
get a promotion or you, you know,
you literally win a
game or whatever it is.
When you have a moment
where you've worked so hard,
you overcame the obstacles and you've
got that moment where you're, you're,
you get the trophy,
you get that feeling of wow,
the hard work pays off
and to have those moments,
and I think Ninja Warrior is filled
with that and for so many of the people,
it's not about getting to the
end and winning the money.
It's getting on the course for,
we had a girl, Daniela Bright,
I think it was season six, I was live
tweeting the show and she said, you know,
if I ever get out of bed, I'd love to be
on the show. I'm like, why are you in bed?
She's like,
well,
I have stage three breast cancer and
I'm not sure how it's gonna turn out.
And so I sent her a tee shirt and I said,
well,
we'll be here waiting for you the
next year. Wow. She's on the course.
She goes out on the first obstacle and
comes out with the biggest smile on her
face. And, and you know, our sideline
reporter was like, how are you feeling?
She goes, I won. Yeah, I'm here.
I feel amazing. And to see
that, to see someone, you know,
what a perspective on life when we so
often get caught up and I did the Patriots
win, or who cares, you know,
those are real battles that these people
are having that we're all gonna face.
They're all going to be touched
by. And to remember that, you know,
in the face of those you can still
struggle and overcome and find your little
victories.
I think that's the message of Ninja
where and why the show's resonated.
What do you make of the fact that Ninja
Warrior or what Rogan's doing with MMA,
like people doing physical things
seems to be actually like cool. Again,
I think it's, it's, it's, you know, it's a
primitive part of us. It's the gladiators.
It's, it's, it's also, you know,
particularly as we get more and more
static as we sit around on our phones,
we miss that. You miss that as a kid. You
miss playing. You miss that feeling of,
one of the things that I know rheumatoid
arthritis took away from me was my
sense of physical wellbeing.
That ability to spring out of bed and
feel like you could run around and run for
hours and, and it's, it's,
it's that idea of to see people achieving
something physically at a high level
inspires you and makes you feel motivated.
I think that that is possible.
Especially, you know, MMA or NFL,
we love watching exceptional performances
with Ninja. What I think the appeal is,
is the idea of that could be me,
maybe I have a chance
to turn this around and,
and get back in shape one last time and
do something amazing. And I think that's,
you know, we're, we're looking for
inspiration. We're looking for hope.
I think that's part of humanity is
we want to, we want to be inspired.
We want to find that spark and,
and wake up and feel like
there's hope in the world.
And that's why I love doing what I do.
I love, you know, with Ninja Warrior,
with my comedy, I want to, I want people
to leave feeling better. Um, uh, you know,
again, Love Stan, hope,
love, Arusha, fair love.
Those guys who can tear a crowd
apart. Love it. I can't do it.
I suck out. I've tried doing roasts,
I bombed, I'm so bad. I was just like,
I'm sorry. I don't know how to
install you to your face or a socket.
This make fun of me. And you
know, it's, it's just, it's,
I think that's part of kind of finding
authentically where you are and what,
what resonates with you and
where you're comfortable.
And that's one of the things know we
talk about people hear this in comedy,
finding your voice, who you are
and what you're comfortable with.
And that is one of the hardest things
to do because so often we emulate those,
we respect, but that's not us. You
really have to dig inside and say,
where do I live? What's my sense of
humor? And Gary Gulman right now,
if you're a comedian or even if
you're just interested in expression,
Gary Gulman is putting on a clinic since
January 1st he's been putting out a
writing tip every day
and they'd been gold.
And one of the best was he put out Ralph
Waldo Emerson's essay on self reliance
and it talked about,
so often we see our thoughts reflected
in someone else and think they're genius.
But when it comes through us,
we dismissed them because it's ours.
We think it's common and it's like
trust yourself, trust that your enough.
It's you know,
then paraphrasing here.
But I thought it was just such a
good for someone who's creative.
So often you think of something like,
oh,
that's not as funny as what Patrice
would've said if George Carlin would have
said.
But it's like no,
trust your way and you're on the
path and just keep developing it.
So before we wrap up,
you mentioned,
so you mentioned that you had cancer
and you have rheumatoid. Yeah,
that's the thing. You can't really, right.
It's no cure yet. You control basically.
Um, no. Let's just talk a little bit about
dealing with some serious health stuff.
Cause someone, yeah, the
average person watching this,
looking at you like you're jack than
you and you look healthy and all those
things, but you've, you've lived through,
it's about it and you talk about it. Yeah.
Well, you know, and that was
one of the things. So, you know,
having been a doctor or as my dad points
are, you're still a doctor champ. Um,
[inaudible] when I was diagnosed
with rheumatoid arthritis,
I found out what it's
like to be a patient.
And you go online and you look things up,
you see the worst case scenario because
that's the textbook they show you,
you know,
the typically deformed joints and you
think this is my future and it gives you
this sinking feeling.
And I realized that's why I was so
important for me to be out there,
visible telling my story. Um,
so that people would see there,
there there's alternatives.
You know,
not everyone living with the
disease is destroyed by it.
We have incredible new treatments.
And just the other day I got a call from
someone who I'd been baseball with in
college, a new, and, uh, he
thought he had ra and he was just,
he was petrified and it was so,
and he's like,
I was just googling it and I found out,
he's like, I didn't know you had it.
I just googled it and found you had
it because you'd talked about it.
And I thought, Oh, you
know, that's why I tell it.
So that this person who called me up
and I could tell my story and say, look,
there's hope. There's treatments.
Don't worry about this. You know,
whatever it is you're facing.
They're incredible treatments out there.
And that's why I went on celebrity
apprentice. That was my charity.
We raised $1 million
to help with research.
And so it's, um, look, I,
I would much prefer not to
have rheumatoid arthritis.
And what level of pain are you going
through when you realized? So it started,
it started with pain in my hand. And um,
it just, it's for those who don't know,
Ra essentially is an autoimmune disease
where my body attacks my joints and the
immune system erodes the joints and
causes joint destruction, inflammation,
and can impact the Oregons, the stiffness
in the back and neck. And, and, uh,
so I went from, you know, being,
working out five or six days a week
to not working out at all. I had, um,
my feet were in pain where I was wearing
clogs and limping. I couldn't sleep.
I was sleeping like 14 hours, but I was
always exhausted. I gained 55 pounds.
I felt like a shell of a man.
I, I, I was physically ruined.
And then it took 18 months to get the
diagnosis and I was going to doctors.
I was having blood work. It just took
that long for the blood work to convert.
And when I started the treatment,
I got my life back. Um,
and I didn't realize how sick
I was and not just physically,
but emotionally how drained I was.
And the thing that kept me going
was comedy, was that, you know,
the thing that I would get out of bed for,
the thing that would motivate me was to
go out and laugh and to realize Norman
cousins was right. Like the
Catharsis of laughter and how, how,
how good those endorphins
are, how important it is. Um,
I can't overstate it and that's one of
the things I've talked about is, you know,
for people who are sick is taught telling
your story because so often people
with the disease field defined by their
disease and one of the things I've done
is tried to make my stories what I talk
about, rheumatoid arthritis or cancer.
I want people to laugh.
I'm going to move me to laugh
about it because if they do,
they know I'm okay with it and I am
okay with it. Like cancer, I'm 10 years,
I'm cured in the Ra, I've
made my peace with it. I'm,
I'm doing well on my medications and
I'm living the best life I can with it.
So people take their cues from you.
So teaching people how to tell
their story because so many people,
when they tell a story of illness,
they feel they can see PT and people's
eyes and that they may not want that.
But it's hard to,
to learn how to tell your story in
a way that says I'm okay with it.
And that's one of the things I've been
working on is trying to figure out how to
help people take,
take charge over their disease by doing
what you can control is how you tell
your story and trying to use, for me
it's humor, but for whatever they're,
there are so many tools, uh, for people
who are dealing with chronic illness,
um, to try to make it, you know,
don't let it define your life because
it's very easy and it's very easy to,
to fall into the victim, you know,
and feeling sad for yourself.
That'd be a shame if you did that.
Wilford Brimley you might have diabetes
feel sorry for yourself. You don't,
all right, so do what makes you happy.
That's how we started this thing.
Live the best life that you can.
That's how we're going to do,
and I think you're doing it today,
so I appreciate you having me on.
Right on that. It's been a pleasure
chatting with you. Thank you.
And for more on Matt,
you can follow them on Twitter.
It's Matt Iseman and that's ice with Ns.
Thanks guys.